mon frère joseph il est mort l'an
dernier
il est parti j'arrive pas encore à me
faire à l'idée
c'est à cause de toi si joseph est mort
tu as détruit ma famille
et ça tu es complètement égal
je suis vraiment heureuse qu'on se
retrouve enfin acquis dit oui
ça va être la fête je vous ai déjà parlé
de mon petit paysan doit dire qu on est
une bande du petit port choix de merde
il se passe quelque chose de terrible je
suis complètement agen
tout est vraiment en amour ici j'entre
dans le premier cercle la place de
meilleur ami les prises du jour au
lendemain comme ça tu es devenue sa
meilleure amie tu lui a piqué son copain
t'es sûr qu'on fait pas une connerie
on va le faire pour lui
je ne sais plus en qui je peux avoir
confiance
la fête est finie à idées on va chercher
des affaires
ici vous vous des tours en l'air c'est
votre passage
[Musique]
quel droit tu te permet de te mêler de
ma vie
tu veux pas montrer une autre facette de
toi
je veux savoir ce qui me fait peur
[Musique]
malade mental je voudrais qu'il ya une
avalanche qui déboule qui on se blesse
une bonne fois pour toutes ce village et
si on sait vous trompez